what makes mozart sound like mozart and
when you do recognize his music what are
you actually listening to
in this video we're going to try to
answer this very question by reverse
engineering his music and applying his
compositional techniques to the tune
happy birthday to try to see if we can
imitate mozart's style this is part of
an ongoing series where i investigate
the styles of famous classical composers
so do subscribe and check out those
other episodes if you're interested in
this topic
so wolfgang amadeus mozart or as he was
formerly baptized johannes christos
thomas wolfgangus theophilus mozart is
indeed one of the most famous composers
of all time he lived a brief but
brilliant 35 years from 1756 to 1791 and
in this time he created beloved works
such as his requiem in d minor
[Music]
his c major piano sonata
and his symphony in g minor
many revere him others not so much
i think mozart especially in his later
years was not a very good composer too
many of his works sound like interoffice
memos his life and personality has been
turned into one of the most entertaining
biographies and his name has become
synonymous with the words genius and
child prodigy with all of this exposure
i bet you think you can recognize his
style right away i certainly did but now
i have some second thoughts
before we get started let's play a quick
game i'm going to play three excerpts
for you try to guess if each one was
written by mozart or not
[Music]
so of those three there was only one
written by mozart and that is the middle
one the fugue the first one was actually
written by a.i
[Music]
i think it sounds pretty legit at this
point we composers should be a little
afraid for jobs but there are some clues
near the end that give it away for me
it doesn't resolve here even though it
can
it doesn't really feel like a cadence
but still ai is getting there
so this view was indeed written by
mozart it's k401
and this sounds a lot like baroque music
with heavy influence from js bach and
this last one here
is something that i wrote using the star
spangled banner theme
[Music]
using some of the concepts i'm about to
cover in this video i'm drawing my notes
from mozart's piano sonatas because he
wrote so much music i have to narrow
this down somehow while i do this i want
to take a moment to thank henley verlag
the sponsors of this video this is
extremely exciting for me because i've
used henley scores for as long as i can
remember this represents only about a
third of my collection and even in a
world where we're using ipads all the
time which by the way they have a
beautiful digital collection there's so
many good things that i could say about
the format the feel the paper the
quality is so high so much research goes
into making these editions a reliable
source for us to study the scores of
these great composers and by the way
something that i think is quite
important is to not be afraid to get in
there and break in your scores by making
markings not being afraid to use ink and
colored markers so i basically went
through these sonatas and marked up a
bunch of segments that i thought
represented this typical mozart sound
the best one thing you can't go wrong
with when it comes to mozart's style is
the alberti base
it's basically a pattern that's applied
to a cord
or really any other variation of that i
would bet that if i scroll through these
pages randomly and stop at any two pages
there is a
two out of three chance that there will
be
some form of alberti base
[Music]
another one just for good measure
i promise you that none of this was
rigged so let's start off with that
alberti base onto
[Music]
happy birthday this is an express road
into the sound world of mozart but
we're only 70 of the way there the
remaining 30 percent is very difficult
in my opinion
so call and response is so important
it's really speech-like and it's a part
of dialogue a lot of his lines a lot of
his melodies and a lot of his
temperament can be related to opera
[Music]
so this is kind of a comic opera maybe
but i want to make it a little sweeter
[Music]
for this to really turn into something
that's call and response we need two
parts
[Music]
maybe closer
we need a scale pattern that is
staggered somehow
[Music]
maybe so we want to repeat this twice
because mozart has this formula that he
uses all the time
he presents an idea then he repeats it
with or without variations
[Music]
ah not quite we're already starting from
a point where the melody the theme
sounds like it's already been decorated
so let's pull back a little
and then from there i think we have more
room to add variations we can gather a
lot of clues from his theme and
variations we can see exactly how he
decorates lines and chords
[Music]
not quite there yet but we're getting
closer
[Music]
now a very important ingredient
is the right temperament i find that a
lot of his music carries this playful
confidence to it i think it comes from
this theatrical quality
so let's add in some lines that have
this sort of bouncy energy to them
[Music]
even when the music is more somber or
fiery there's this mannerism that's
attached to it that makes it almost feel
like you're wearing a costume and you're
on stage and you're acting out this part
just so that our ears don't lose track
of the theme let's take a fragment of it
and use it to create this little
interjection
and mozart always switches gears it's a
form of contrast and also different
characters coming in and out
[Music]
so from here let's switch gears
maybe another imitation thing here
now a very important thing is to have
form most of his piano sonatas follow
either a sonata allegra form minuet in
trio form rondo form demon variations
and he doesn't veer away from this too
much
here's an example of one of mozart's
primary themes
and here is the secondary theme in the
key of the dominant
so in order to follow the sonata a labor
form we need a second theme and i'm
going to choose a minor for that
and that comes from happy birthday
not quite
maybe that what i love about mozart's
music is that once you're immersed in
his sound world he makes it so that
every musical event
every chord change every new idea
is quite dramatic when he presents
something new there's weight to it
and that's why a simple
[Music]
diminished chord
resolving is so dramatic and i'm going
to insert something like this
let's add in a little turn here
now comes the fun part the development
where we can go to different key centers
a lot of times there's this stormier
quality here and there's a lot of
tension a lot of conflict
so here i think i'm using too many notes
that is probably enough
not quite
i want to use this pattern because i
think it is very dramatic you see it in
a lot of passages it's really
reminiscent of strings
that's a bit straightforward we need
suspensions this and then intervals that
then resolve
something like that and also i'm turning
this into of course a sequence and this
is an easy way to transport this
material through different keys
and from here my job is to wrap up the
development section in a way that makes
our ears anticipate the return of the
two themes so basically have our ears
ready primed to return back to where we
started so with these things in mind i
went ahead and finished the arrangement
and now i'd like to finally present to
you my arrangement of happy birthday in
the style of mozart
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so now it's your turn let me know in the
comments below how close you think i got
to mozart's style and what you think was
missing let me know let's educate each
other so that i can take notes thank you
so much again to henley for sponsoring
this video thank you to my patrons on
patreon and for you all for watching and
subscribing make sure you check out
these videos covering the styles of
other famous classical composers and
i'll see you in the next video